as you know uh
i've been praising south dakota every
time i've stood up this week
and i have to do it once more in front
of the governor
among the things to admire is its speed
laws
and if you ride motorcycles sometimes
then you'll really love them
um also i've got nowhere i've been
negotiating with south dakotans
all day about my offer to trade
governors
and and my offer to
include six state senators
and the way the negotiations are going
they want me to take
six state senators so you know
i would do that and so i've put the
point to the governor and she's thinking
about it
so it's a remarkable woman um
she's uh negotiated her way through this
mess
brilliantly better than anybody uh
i'd like to say she's the best man in
politics since margaret thatcher
and
um and uh
i i've been reading her speeches and
there's a big reason
why she's been able to negotiate through
this she understands
something she understands the difference
between
common sense and expertise and that was
a great subject
theme subject of winston churchill and
almost nobody understands that today
expert expert knowledge is narrow
knowledge and you can't make decisions
on it by itself ever her career is
spectacular
she grew up on a rancher family her
father was killed in an accident on the
ranch
when he was 42 she told me
she basically took over all that when
she was 22.
she got a big tax bill immediately she
had to restructure her business and
start some more businesses and pay off
that tax bill
and you know it made her mad at the
government
and uh and mad at the tax system
and so then she gets selected at the
state house and then the congress
and now governor and i can't see that
she's ever lost a race
uh and i i've just been encouraging her
to have many more
she's probably the best governor in
america christy noam
well thank you oh my goodness
[Applause]
well thank you welcome to south dakota
we are so thrilled that you're here and
that your meetings have gone
well and that you get a chance to enjoy
a little freedom
know i think to understand the decisions
that i've made uh
you need to understand me a little bit
my background so that's what we were
discussing a little bit at my table
my background how i was raised and
really
the challenges but also the moments of
teaching
and one of the things i'll tell you
before i give you
my words for today and i want to talk a
little bit about freedom i think the
actual topic that i've been given is
political issues and controversies is
your theme
and they wanted me to specifically talk
about liberty and the pandemic so i will
do that
but i also want you to understand that
in the last six months
it has amazed me to watch fear control
people
that that this pandemic really used
emotion and fear to manipulate people in
ways that we've never seen before
and what bothered me early on was
recognizing the fact that when you have
a leader
overstep their authority in a time of
crisis that that's when you lose your
country
so we were talking at our table a little
bit about why i've spoken about the
things that i've spoken about why i've
chosen to use my press conferences
as educational opportunities it was
because it was necessary
it was it became very real to me that i
was making different decisions than
virtually
any other governor in the nation and
that people didn't know why
and that a little bit of our history
constitution the reason
that america is special needed to be
revisited again
and that really is behind a lot of the
decisions that we've had here in south
dakota
so you are in a special place because as
you travel from state to state
you'll see a lot of challenges when you
come to south dakota you realize that
our people are happy
they wake up happy in the morning and
they're optimistic about the future
so for those of you who aren't from
south dakota and you don't know me
i've gotten a lot of attention recently
from the mainstream media
what i tend to say to individuals is six
months ago you
probably had no idea who i was the
reason that you know who i am
is because the mainstream media told the
world that i was the only governor in
america that was making all the wrong
decisions
on how i handled the pandemic in fact
specifically rachel maddow
elizabeth warren the new york times the
washington post
you name it i was the focus of every
single one of their stories
but this week a very prominent national
reporter
wrote me a note and said governor if you
hadn't stood against the lockdowns
we would have had no proof as to how
useless they really have been
so at the start of 2020 i outlined to
all the people in the state about
how we are unique i encouraged
people from across the country to come
to south dakota and the opportunities
that we provided i talked about our
people
about their work ethic their values i
talked about our government how it was
limited
we had a low tax and regulatory
structure and i also talked about
our way of life what made south dakota
special
one that respects uh our and cherishes
the principles of
thrift hard work family and
self-governance
south dakota was second to none and then
a global pandemic hit
so rightly so all of our attention
shifted from telling the country
that south dakota is open for business
to making sure that south dakotans
had the best information available to
them to respond to the virus
now this virus posed many challenges for
us
and the situation has been historic in
the absolute worst way
but with every challenge comes an
opportunity to learn to adapt and to
improve
so let's take a couple of minutes to
walk through some of the lessons that we
have learned
and perhaps the most significant one of
those lessons lessons that we've learned
is that more freedom
and not more government is the answer
now while freedom isn't uh necessarily
the one thing that will solve
all of our problems it will certainly
take us down the road
much farther towards where we want to go
freedom is a much better friend
to true science than government-centered
or government-controlled science freedom
not government is the best friend of
innovation
freedom focuses on politics of
persuasion
and the intellectual strength of all of
our positions
not on control coercion and the heavy
hand of government and if someone is
interested
in the common good in all of its
iterations and complexities
freedom is the one and the only choice
available to us
now my approach to this virus was to
provide south dakotans with all of the
information
that i had available to me and to then
allow them to exercise
their freedom to make the best decisions
for themselves and for their families
we took a unique path we did not
lock people up we did not close any
businesses
in the state of south dakota not once
did we issue a shelter in place
i didn't even define what an essential
business was
because i don't believe that i have the
authority to tell you your business
is an essential
in return the mainstream media spent
countless hours
and endless column inches in their
papers
attacking me for it and frankly that's
the only reason that i'm in the national
spotlight today
is because liberals as i told dr arn
here
is that have literally been kicking me
in the head every night
on national tv for the decisions that i
made for south dakota
rachel maddow elizabeth warren have
relentlessly attacked me night after
night
for the decisions that i've made now
while the washington elites
and the mainstream media hurled their
relentless criticism
the vast majority of south dakotans have
thanked me
they've thanked me for the opportunity
to be trusted
beyond that many of my peers though
apply to one size
fits all lockdown other ordinary
americans though the life mud
of the nation were watching what we were
doing here in south dakota
they saw the different actions that we
were taking and many said
that's exactly the way that i want my
government to treat me
i want my government to trust me not
dictate
to me this leaves me to wonder what does
this stay
what does this say about the state of
our media today
when they hold up elected officials who
they believe are making the wrong
decisions and they attack them
and go after them personally and
politically but yet other
officials that are elected into office
are praised
because they fall into aligned with the
agenda that they have
and they're shielded from real scrutiny
of the results of their actions
and this also brings me to the topic of
modeling now while modeling certainly
has a place
models have two shortcomings today and
really
no model can actually predict the future
and especially when those models are
based
on incomplete information which we saw
widespread throughout the last several
months
and no model can actually replace human
freedom
as the best path to responding to our
life's risks
including in response to this virus that
is why central planning of the economy
including has failed us every single
time the government has tried it
now in south dakota we used modeling as
a tool we used it to prepare for the
worst case scenario should that come
thankfully it never did it still could
in the future and we are prepared for
that
but we have not seen it yet today but
there's no model that can take into
consideration all of the factors that
make real life work
a blind reliance on insufficient
modeling has led some
politicians to institute disastrous
lockdowns that have only jeopardized
people's health
and their welfare but also created
conditions for a financial catastrophe
that will cause untold burdens on costs
of their people for generations to come
the financial burden of government
lockdowns made one thing
one thing clear that urban life isn't
all that it's cracked up to be
in south dakota the rural way of life is
the preferred way of life
folks who want to stay on their land
pass it on to their kids and their
grandkids
they also want to be in their
communities that they've called home for
generations and they want to eat
in small mom and pop restaurants visit
some of the world's most beautiful
places and have their kids spend more
time with their tackle box
rather than an xbox and sure big
famous cities like new york city are
home to some iconic buildings and some
beautiful museums
but they also come with traffic with
noise
congestion and in a post covered world
they're going to come with sanitary
issues as well
as we've seen throughout the pandemic
population density does come with a
steep cost
so some think that covid19 will
accelerate
a move of people out of the cities that
it will
move people to rural areas because of
that preferred way of life but that
story is still being written
one of the few things we know about this
virus is that density is one of the key
factors contributing to the spread
but because of that new york city and
silicon valley could look
very different in the future but the
lessons of this virus do not stop at
city limits
while many can work remotely from their
laptops and definitely
a key takeaway from covid that i've
learned and that i hope all of you learn
is that america's workers the farmers
the truckers
the ranchers plumbers grocers
health care workers the builders in the
and the producers of this country are
more critical than ever
that the fundamentals of life haven't
changed that
people still need the basic necessities
of life
the grocery stores still need to be
stocked lights need to stay on
and doctors need to keep seeing patients
so for those of you
who are the builders and the producers
and the essential workers of today and
you're scattered throughout the country
if you've seen how south dakota has
managed this pandemic and you like it
we'd like you to move to south dakota
[Applause]
to those of you who are professionals
who are working from home permanently
if you value our way of life where
people love freedom
smaller communities lots of wide open
spaces
i'd like you to really consider making
your workplace your workspace
right here in south dakota as well and
for those of you who own businesses
in other states who are frustrated that
your business was forced to close
that you saw one leader's decision
completely take away your life savings
and your way of life
i will remind you we have the
friendliest tax environment in the
entire country
the lowest regulatory burden and we will
not
close your business for you we
trust our business owners to be flexible
we gave them the opportunity to be
innovative and we allowed them to take
care of their customers
and their employees and put food on the
table we would absolutely love for you
to move your business to south dakota
[Applause]
now not all governors in this country
trusted their people like i did
different paths mean that sometimes
people have different choices
but in south dakota like it always does
we choose common sense
if you want freedom personal
responsibility in a government that
works for you rather than dictates to
you
south dakota is the place to get it our
trips to the store might look a little
bit different today and our sporting
events might change but that's not
necessarily a bad thing it's an
opportunity for us to do better to be
innovative to create new ways of serving
each other
but i want to leave you with this
thought no one saw 2020 playing out the
way that it has
each and every one of us has
dramatically changed our day-to-day
lives
we had to adjust to be adaptable and to
all those
who have lost loved ones throughout this
pandemic my heart
breaks for each and every one of you
things will not be the same in the
future but today
we do have a very different opportunity
than we had in the past
don't ever forget this one fundamental
truth
the windshield is much bigger than the
rear view mirror for
for a reason there's a purpose to it in
south dakota we always look at
adversary or adversity we always look at
challenges as an opportunity to do
better
we focus on our future what's in front
of us and it's bright
hope is in front of us we are emerging
from this stronger than ever
and we are concerned what the future may
hold for you
if you don't join us we would love to
have you
in our state and that wherever you are
that if you choose to come to south
dakota just remember this
that the air is fresh the people are
free
and the possibilities here are endless
so thank you
thank you very much for inviting me to
be with you
so i understand we're going to take a
few questions thank you governor gnome
yes uh we now have time for some q a if
you have a question
please raise your hand and wait for a
microphone to be brought to you
thank you governor with your approach to
the pandemic
how have your hospitals
survived with the um with their
capacities
yeah they've done a fantastic job we
have three major health care systems in
the state of south dakota
and we immediately brought them in back
in january that was when we first
started hearing about the virus in other
countries
and i opened up an emergency operations
center
and started working and studying what
was happening in those countries what we
could learn about the virus
before it got to the united states and
then as it came to the united states
what was happening in other states to
learn
so we brought them in at the ground
level and helped us with planning and
implementation and responding to
people's needs and they're doing great
so dr fauci told me on my worst day i'd
have 10 000 people in the hospital from
covid 19.
i think my worst day so far i've had a
little over 200.
so that's one of the things that we did
is even through no mandates we
encouraged people that if they were of
the vulnerable population
to stay home that if they were going to
be older they had health conditions that
could put them in the hospital
that we wanted them to take extra
precautions told them that we would
serve them and help them get groceries
and do those kind of things that
gave people the recommendations on
social distancing all of that but i also
said
in south dakota we're not going to focus
on positive cases of the virus
we know we can't stop this virus the
science tells us that
all we can do is slow it down so that we
have the capacity to take care of people
in our health care systems
what i talked about every single day and
still talk about today
is how many people do we have in the
hospital
that was our main focus was that we made
sure we had the experts ready to respond
at a time of need
so today i have about nine percent of
folks
in my hospital systems are there because
of covid19
i think in my icus 12 of the people that
are there
are there from covid19 so we're in great
shape as it comes to having that
capacity available for those folks that
would catch the virus and need that care
have any other governors called you and
have you given them advice and what
reaction did they have
well that's that's kind of the behind
the scenes that people don't really know
is that we spent hundreds and hundreds
of hours on the phone talking as
governors
you know there's several different
national organizations that facilitated
calls but then there's many of us that
had
individual calls and then groups of
eight or ten of us would all get on
calls and talk
at night as well so what i will tell you
is that
every piece of piece of information that
i had available to me
they had available to them as well i
consulted with all of my
health experts i consulted with my state
epidemiologist my secretary of health
and listened and studied the models one
of the things i think i did that no
other governors did was i also sat on
quite a few conference calls
of nationwide secretaries of health and
listen to them many of those calls i was
the only governor on
the state epidemiologist from every
state would have weekly conference calls
that i would sit on and just listen
i didn't want to rely on somebody else
to to relay to me what was said on those
calls i wanted to learn from myself but
i also
consulted with my general counsel i also
consulted with
attorneys who specifically focus on
constitutional authority
and i wanted to know what authority did
i have that the u.s constitution gives
me
because i have the i have i've taken the
oath to uphold that constitution and i
wanted to know what the constitution of
the state of south dakota
told me my authority was and what it
wasn't
so i came at it from that viewpoint of
really what my role was as governor
and what my role wasn't and i had all
those debates
and discussions with all those governors
before they made their decisions to
institute
lockdowns and mandates and those were
conversations that we did have they just
made a different choice
but i one one of the honest
conversations too that i
i mean it wouldn't be unfair for me to
say that every
if i did not point out that every
governor has a different situation
but i do know that in listening to them
talk i heard the fear in their voices
they were dealing with a health crisis
and
often the response i would get would be
christie but if i
do that people might die and that that
was what they really wrestled with so i
think the reality of it being in
leadership at this point in time was a
very lonely place to be
you know we all have incredible teams
around us that give us advice and give
us wisdom
but ultimately when the final decision
had to be made it was
that governor that had to make that
decision for me it was
okay governor now you need to decide and
i had to make it so
that really was the challenge i think
governors faced and
while they had the information they knew
their authorities
some of them made very different
decisions and i think for their people
it's extremely unfortunate we have a
question on the speakers right
sure i'm a cresty old veteran
and on behalf of my network of crusty
old veterans we want to thank you you
are the governor who most embodies the
freedom we all entered military service
to defend
besides that a lot of my veteran friends
are constantly talking and asking
what can we do as ordinary people to
advance freedom in this world where we
get shut down on social media where
we get yelled at if we bring up a point
that's not the normal narrative
and we just feel helpless a lot of the
time and
love to hear what you think we can do
okay can i just tell you how remarkable
this is right now
we have somebody who served in our
military went
and risked their lives to defend our
freedom asking what more they can do
to defend our freedom
[Applause]
so that's what is incredible about our
country
and we should be able to turn on our
nightly news and see stuff like that
rather than the garbage we have to watch
every single night
but thank you for serving our country
and
and for doing that due diligence to make
sure that we are intact and we're the
special country that we are today
what i would say is that we need you to
be normal people
and to go out and have conversations
that you're not having today
i'll get real candid here for a minute
but when you go
fill your car with gas are you asking
the person at the pump next to you who
they're voting for and why
and having that conversation when you go
to church are you talking to people
about
how important it is that america's
fundamental freedoms are protected and
you know that's we all have these
conversations in our groups and we
but there's people that we just avoid
that conversation with and we also need
to remember not to do it in an
aggressive mean manner you know we
people will be attracted to us by our
optimism
by our hope i honestly feel like and i'm
a republican and i'm proud to be a
republican that all we did here in south
dakota was we implemented
the republican platform that we say we
believe
other people stand up as republicans and
say they believe it but they never do it
we actually did it
and so what we've seen now is incredible
benefits to people that now we can point
to as it actually works
but i also know that for many people we
are paying the consequences for how we
speak to each other
how we talk to each other has
consequences and we have dehumanized
each other throughout that process
so we need to remind each other that we
are people
and have a heart connection with them
and when we're talking to them really
listen and and and tell your stories i
think your stories would be most
impactful how you decided to go into the
military how you decided to protect this
country and why it was important and
then use every opportunity to teach
people
because that's what i realized
throughout this pandemic was nobody
really knows or reflects
on our history and what it brings to us
this tearing down of our monuments
breaks my heart
it is our history and these people were
not perfect i'm not perfect who of you
out here has lived up to your own ideals
we have flawed leaders that helped our
country get through challenging times
and did incredible things for us we
didn't say they were perfect
but we can learn from them and they're
part of our history
and that's one of the things that i
think people are not reflecting on today
so just don't lose sight of the value of
individuals
and their willingness to have a
conversation and remember to be
happy you know i'm i'm a
christian and i believe that people are
attracted to us
because they want more of what we have
and if you
give the persona that it's all
negativity and ugliness and condemning
and judgmental
that doesn't really attract people to
the right viewpoint of what's special
about america
last last thing i'll say on this point
is
and i'm sure my staff is tired of
hearing me say this ian's laughing
you know we all love to be offended
this country is addicted to being
offended aren't they
i mean i they really are we we turn on
the news and somebody says something oh
it's so offensive that they said that
and we can't believe it and
it's just unbelievable and we just
really need to get over ourselves
you know it we really do
i had a pastor tell me one time he said
christy people are going to throw out of
fences all the time you're the one who
decides if you want to pick him up and
carry him around
he says then you're the one carrying the
burden so who's losing in that situation
i think that's true
people are going to offend us all the
time and we need to just decide we're
going to let it lay walk by it
and just go on and be happy and
understand that what we have is special
governor i'm here from minnesota and i
just want to say i'm enjoying breathing
the free air
um last spring i'm not sure exactly when
i'd heard you interviewed on hannity i
believe
talking about hydroxy chloroquine and
some studies that you were going to
do and of course any positive news about
that it would never
receive the light of day so i'm just
wondering if you could talk a little bit
was that something that you brought to
fruition and what if anything
came of that yes we in south dakota did
the first
ever statewide state-backed
partnership with our all of our health
care systems
on a trial on hydroxychloroquine
that's never happened before in the
country but where the state government
partnered with our three major
health care systems to open it up to
every single person if the state if they
want to participate
it was remarkable we have several
sanford health is our
health care system in the state that has
the research arm to it
and is doing several different trials on
therapeutics but also vaccines and has
been very helpful throughout the
pandemic to get the facts and
information out
we have time for one more question sure
hi i certainly appreciate the fact that
you're here christy
uh i married a south dakota gal back in
1951 and have a lot
a lot of in-laws and outlaws back in the
sioux falls there you do
seriously i've lived in montana now but
in illinois wisconsin minnesota and
michigan and i'm sick to have to admit
that the governors of those places
followed up so badly
you had one incredible instance at the
old morel plant
in sioux falls smithfield i guess owns
it up
how did you have it was a big hot spot
and everything how did you happen to
handle that so quickly
and it disappeared as a negative
thing for you well you know and we've
seen these in different parts of the
country but we had a
a group of positive cases come out of a
meat processing facility
and we went in there and addressed it
worked with a company brought our health
care officials in
to do testing to get people the
information that they needed
and many of these families that worked
there were living in close quarters
working in close quarters and so it was
natural that it would spread but i think
what was
important was that we didn't overreact
we took care of people
and and that was important we got it
under control and i told people from the
very beginning
that we're going to see cases go up
cases go down people we're going to have
different counties different communities
that are going to have an increase in
cases and then go back down
i said there may be days that i stand in
front of you and i
say we have thousands of new cases i've
never had to do that yet but
i prepared people for the fact that if
that were to happen that would be
expected
and so calming people down and letting
them know what was in the future and
being truthful i think was incredibly
helpful
but by not getting distracted
or pressured by media and people who had
an agenda beyond taking care of people i
think was incredibly important
my secretary of health said to me one
day before the pandemic even started in
south dakota
she said governor i just want to tell my
team do you want to make decisions that
make people feel good
or do you want to do good and i said we
will always
do good so we took the emotion out of
our decision making right away
so that we could focus on the facts in
the science and the data of what was
happening here in our state
and use that to make sure that we're
implementing things that actually worked
please join me in thanking governor
gnome thank you everybody
[Applause]
you